good trashiest story in the world I hope
my parents don't hear whatever well the
whole thing is upsetting high school
past college totally forgot to even try
moved out to Los Angeles two years after
I graduated cool two years after moving
out to Los Angeles I'm doing open mics
and all of my material is about being a
26 year old virgin fine whatever I
wasn't really in a rush for whatever
reason I was like dad lives this long
without it but then I came up with a
joke about who's like having sex for the
first time so I get the joke and it did
well for an open mic but then a bunch of
people who have heard me talk about
being a virgin then heard me talk about
losing my virginity and they had a lot
of questions and I just lied and said
that I did obvious things that I didn't
and then I was like all right you don't
have to be a liar forever so then on
Monday I was like all right I'm not
gonna do comedy tonight Oh another
important part of this story is that I
was technically home was it but stuff I
was living on people's couches
he's only house-sitting and occasionally
sleeping in my car so I was
house-sitting for one of my more
successful friends I was like right
today's the day baby had about a billion
glasses of white wine started planting
the seed on tinder swiping swipe it on
anything I get myself a date perfect I
get to the bar sitting at the bar mind
you I'm already a little bit drunk he
walks in wearing neon glasses and he
tries to feed me a cookie that he
stopped to get on the way before even
saying hello and I was like you're
stupid he called me a [ __ ] the
bartender's like what's this guy's deal
he said he was leaving the bartender
stepped and was like that's a good idea
you should go
the bartender pours me another drink and
I noticed his beautiful eyes I was like
oh [ __ ]
alright bartender so I give him my
number and he is not into it fine
all right I'm pulling out all the stuff
I'm drunk Facebook messaging people I
look for anyone at this point a Monday
night is anyone going to be into this
turns out someone was and so he comes
over I have like my shoes off like he
knows I'm not going out that we sit down
I give him some wine make sure he's nice
and drunk he wanted to get drunk I need
that to be done he had been drinking -
everyone was equally drunk on purpose
consensual the funny thing is is that I
knew we were gonna have sex he didn't
know that it was so funny to watch him
be really pulling out the stops being
flirty he tried to play footsie it I was
like unnecessary nothing's enough
bedrooms that way you could follow me or
not he goes oh you want it huh and I was
like sure know that yeah thanks I feel
nothing even if he does see this no one
knows who this guy is his penis was what
I would imagine you take an American
girl sock and fill it with one of those
bouncy balls but I thought and I was
like probably make a difference I've
never had said it does make a difference
he was probably getting ready to warm me
up and it took God loved him
he finishes I do not I'm texting all my
friends being like I [ __ ] did it for
real he leans over and whispers in my
ear give me ten minutes and I'll [ __ ]
you like that again and I was like hey
what do we say we call you an uber he
just goes hey wait a second did you only
call me over to have sex with me like it
just dawned on him 26 later and then he
got in his Oberon he left and then I was
able to do that joke and then I stopped
doing stand-up a few months look I think
I deleted tinder after that even so I
was just like I got what I needed
I know how the story sounds wolf a guy
did that too a girl would be shitty it's
like ya know what I did was shitty I
know you know I'm assuming he wasn't
broken by it you know one wants to feel
used right what I did super shitty but
he was cool with it because I think
tradition
nothing is right or wrong it's what is
guys are sort of taught sex doesn't mean
as much girls are taught that you are
supposed to love that person otherwise
you're a hoe
if you've sad about it I am sorry
comments reach out and say sorry maybe
comment privately because I did say what
your penis looks like hahaha yeah no I'm
a piece there that's just it that's
another thing this is a really important
thing being an [ __ ] is not strictly
reserved for guys
[Music]